let me tell you a little story about
Congressman Adrian Smith a Republican
from Nebraska congressman Smith was
asked whether every American is entitled
to eat during an interview with NPR's
Scott Simon now this is a really very
interesting bit of insight into the
overarching principles that dictate the
views of many Republicans from really
what's a moral level and and I want to
dig into that in a moment but first
we've got to just get the facts down
this was an interview on NPR about the
farm bill and the proposed cuts that
Donald Trump has to SNAP benefits Snap
colloquially known as food stamps in his
budget proposal seeking to cut close to
200 million dollars over ten years
that's about 25% of the program's cost
over that period congressman Smith tried
to focus on oh well we can make small
changes to this or that but I'm I'm glad
that on NPR he was actually pushed about
what's the underlying principle here is
every American entitled to eat and Smith
tries to divert with vagaries about
nutrition is important blah blah blah
but Scott Simon cuts to the chase and
gets through get sort of gets to the
nonsense that underlies the principle
let's take a listen here well I think at
any time we're talking about food and a
nutrition it's an important topic and
especially for for people in need we do
not want to leave our most vulnerable
without nutrition right and looking at
that we always want to keep that in mind
we do know that the nutrition title of
the farm bill is it's the largest one
when it comes to the dollars okay and so
even even very minor shifts it can be
very effective in terms of fiscal policy
and at the same time make sure that we
do not harm the most vulnerable among us
well let me ask you this bluntly is
every american entitled to eat well the
nutrition obviously we know is very
important hope that we can little well
not just important it's essential for
life is every american entitled
is essential it is essential so is every
American entitled to eat and his food
stamp something that ought to be that
ultimate guarantor I think that we we
know that given the necessity of
nutrition there could be a number of
ways that we could address that yeah
it's so you would you would vote to a
for a budget that cuts food stamps I
want to look at an entire budget look at
all of the details yeah is every
American entitled to eat well we've
determined nutrition is important yeah
you kind of can't survive without it
given the necessity of nutrition there
could be any number of ways that we
address that is every American entitled
to breathable air doctors have told us
air is important and I think on that we
can all agree right but given that the
air is so important do we want to make
sure that there's breed of breathable
air for everybody this is another clown
congressman no shock there but the big
thing is this is reflective of the
worldview of people in the Republican
Party no you're not entitled to eat
unless you earned it it's terrible for
our country as a whole to have people
going hungry well unless you've earned
having food you don't get food and we've
talked about this sort of strict father
morality as I call it and as others call
it as well with abortion right oh you're
against abortion hey great news we
figured out how to reduce the number of
abortions you prevent pregnancies and
the way to do that is access to birth
control and comprehensive sex education
nope you know why because on some level
morally if you have sex you deserve to
have a baby
well at least didn't use that right wing
talking point that making people
entitled to food would be tantamount to
enslaving farmers as right Rand Paul
uses when he's talking about health care
this is part of the affliction that
you're pointing out Pat of so-called
fiscal conservatism which is usually not
conservative in the long run and is
often completely immoral with hunger we
can fix this we could have fixed hunger
a long time ago if you look at food
production we've spoken to food experts
on the program before if you look at the
number of calories produced every day on
our planet and you look at the number of
people that live
our plan a pretty simple division
equation we have more than enough food
now to feed everyone but with food waste
as well as the lack of proper allocation
of resources we have people that are
hungry but it is a completely solvable
problem should anyone be surprised that
congressman Smith answered in this way
or that there are Republicans who just
don't believe everybody is entitled to
eat obviously not look at what just
happened in Montana we're going to talk
about that next
Montana elected a man to Congress the
day after he body-slammed a reporter for
asking a question so chances are that a
guy who simply doesn't think everybody
has a right to eat is also going to be
an elected official it's depressing to
watch but this is America today and you
know Republicans justify increased
military spending by saying well you
know all other freedoms come after our
security and everything else is
secondary or I think you can use the
same logic when it comes to food if you
don't have you're not entitled to food I
don't think you're entitled to much else
who's gonna be in the military if you
don't have food it's gonna be tough
obviously that's not the people in the
military have earned the right to eat
not everybody has apparently according
to congressman Smith you're absolutely
disgusting we really appreciate the
support of our sponsors including
today's sponsor tag add AB the hosting
specialist they've got a great special
offer for our viewers which I'll tell
you about in a second whether you are
looking for cloud server solutions
virtual private server dedicated server
solutions custom server solutions
colocation services whatever you're
looking for tag a DAB offers it and
they're very proud of their hosting
specialist team you not only have a team
of experts in this field but those
experts also make up their support team
so you actually get what is clearly
something that is so important to tag a
DAB as evidenced by their nine point
seven out of ten Trustpilot review
rating which is really good customer
service more and more people are
interested in going in the direction of
cloud server solutions and you can get a
ten British pound credit towards a new
account at sign up tag a DAB comm /td PS
check that out
ten British Pound free credit at signup
tag adapt calm /t DPS